[music playing]
NARRATOR: Nestling on the east
bank of the Nile, Nefertiti's
capital city covered
over 3,000 acres,
and was home to up
to 50,000 people.
What is now barren landscape
was once one of the greatest
cities in the ancient world.
And from these
palaces and temples,
the royal couple ruled
over all of Egypt.
She doesn't appear
to be buried here,
but does this place
hold clues to the fate
of the missing queen?
Nefertiti is famous
today because
of this iconic bust of her.
She has one of the
most well-known
faces in all of ancient Egypt.
This is about the spot that
the bust was actually found.
We're in the house and the
workshop of a sculptor who was
probably called Thutmose,
This is where the Nefertiti
bust was originally created.
It's one version of
Nefertiti's official portrait.
She may herself have
signed off on this image.
But really, we have no idea what
she looked like in real life.
NARRATOR: Nefertiti's early
life is also still a mystery.
Her father was probably
Ay, vizier to pharaoh
Amenhotep III, so
she would have been
brought up in a royal palace.
By the age of just
15, she married
Amenhotep's second son,
the new pharaoh Akhenaten,
and bore him six daughters.
As his queen, Nefertiti
became the most
powerful woman in all of Egypt.
Yet Nefertiti's ultimate fate
remains a mystery that occupies
archaeologists all over Egypt.